there's been an atrophying of you
knowing yourself as
source most simply put you've atrophied
your true nature
as source now you think you're a person
a very contracted form of identity
that is the very nature of reality is
the fact that
you are deluded into your contraction
of identity rather than knowing yourself
as the source
of awareness and the source of these
realities
it starts within it starts with your
identity
are you a person are you awareness are
you the absolute are you the source of
awareness and of reality and do you see
how it's all
one intelligence at play and how there
is no sense of i
do you see that because if you see that
if you know that
you can't commit malevolence you can't
commit suffering
because you become the maximal shepherd
you no longer come from your
conditioning but you come from
source boom
your very nature as source simulates the
sense of
i in order for it to be able to witness
infinite creation
it's unbelievably genius we
are that which is genius
as source designing the nature
of the illusory intoxicative eye to
infinitely
witness creation
and that this very last pop from the
sense of self
to the sense of no self from the very
ottman
to the anatman to the very anata the
very no
self is mission critical for you to know
this is one massive your nature
as source creating this one mass of
decentralized
swarm intelligence god's love light
leela that
plays endlessly in its creations
and so we need this navigable road map
it's mission critical so much of the
planet is still stuck in this third
density matrixy
governments and politicians and economic
machinery
and media propaganda and fast food high
fructose corn syrup all these
nonsensical indoctrinated belief
structures and they have absolutely no
will and no choice and no self-awareness
and no sovereignty but you have to
recognize that you
are that i am that i am
all of those costumes and for me to
create the architectures
that enable these costumes to awaken is
the coolest thing that i could possibly
do
boom